80% of my time in LA has been spent so
far look at this yes good morning today
is a really weird day because you can't
even see it's raining in LA what is this
laughs I don't believe this it's been
raining since 3:00 in the morning
there's been a drought in LA for like
three years so I'm guessing people are
pretty happy right now get so foggy stop
edge that's my underwear you're welcome
good news number one positive
that's awesome great news number two we
want to stream you last night
ah-yi I really wanted to go it was just
such a crazy day of shooting there's no
way I could have but thank you bros for
voting that's amazing I honestly didn't
think we were gonna win it so thank you
both so much forwarding that's so cool
are you ready for the final good news
legend of the brofist the pewdiepie game
is coming out the 24th of September that
should be in seven days let's be honest
what else are you gonna do with your
life
I'll show something new every day okay
we go oh my god who's gonna save me now
it's not really a good time jump on my
jet you're what
yeah kid show too much because they will
spoil the surprise
let's count it down seven days that's a
week
be prepared I like in gadgets title
YouTube's PewDiePie is definitely not
starring in a TV show to be fair it's
not 100% true and there's more news - I
am in LA that no one knows about yet so
yeah I'm still ahead let's go and wake
up March ant sleep yet waiting for marks
yeah so I'm going to build duckling
number two
someone's at our door hello
no thank you let's go bro let's go
their son is out let's go smoke I feel
like I need new shoes I feel like I
can't walk around with blood on my shoes
look who finally got what she wanted
worst place on the planet coming right
up
fun fun what's there
we're walking to the groove this phone
is a burner phone like all the drug
dealers
I feel pretty cool alright we're going
there but look good
Casey Murr this place is really cool
he reminds me of Disneyland for some
reason okay that's great that you can
hear me Wow
I bought some basic stuff that I didn't
bring and we're gonna have lunch we're
eating at all right we just had lunch
now we're gonna go to another place and
it will be great thank you my dad for
filling my blogs okay
I lost Marzia a little in front of me
we're finally heading back are you
feeling
we went out way longer than I thought
okay I'm gonna try on some of the stuff
that I bought I like this one very baggy
I like this mom because you can see my
nipple right there oh I love them that
pole one and a half hour until my
shooting begins today
I'll probably just relax a bit ah man I
gotta tell ya
vlogging is hard I'm having a blast in
LA I'm really because I prepare for this
trip for so long and I'm just really
glad that all the effort was worth it
alright excuse me I'm gonna get back to
work
and what I'm joined by this loser I'm
supposed to get in a car and I don't
know where it's gonna take me red car
going in a red car with a weird-ass
driver all right all right it's 9:00
p.m. not what we're not doing anything
we're not doing anything stop Duke what
is your problem all right look at this
yell worse than me 80% of my time in LA
has been spent so far look at this guy's
oh [ __ ] the camera oops sorry it nice
one
it's almost 10 o'clock we haven't shot
anything properly yet I got a cocktail
and a pizza this is great if I don't
show up tomorrow you know these guys
will kill me
quality shoot her doesn't want me to
talk about the show I don't understand
why cuz we're doing some quality stuff
on this thing that we're shooting
obviously this is what really has
project over at my space playing in a
band as they're driving the motor side
yeah okay yeah all right you got me
ahh I don't know how people think
Hollywood works but this is Hollywood a
lot of like a lot of alcohol and a lot
of sitting around and a look at this guy
oh yeah [ __ ] him up we're heading back
home and he needs to wash his car his
front car window Oh what the [ __ ] is
going on what the [ __ ] happened then why
are you back here
so done
hey judo Thursday hi I will I'm vlogging
for my phone it's probably [ __ ] I'm home
the boys are sleeping he's sleeping
what yeah yeah I found that done for the
day tomorrow the day off we're gonna
meet up with PJ and Sophie fun day I
guess I don't I don't know what to say
I'll see you tomorrow breakfast I can't
tell you what happened but I can show
you my clothes just because it's fun
doesn't make it easy we're sorry to see
you rocket and we're cheering for you
every step of the way love your friends
I eat at some sweet